eso es bueno y la energia
después de manejar la motocicleta por más de 120
mil kilómetros al sur de
América para más historias asombrosas de
pueblos miran mas gente yo
lo que preguntan es si bajo el miedo al que fui alli a
situacion que youtube mas teme
hoy gugu ya es un gran proyecto en na
amazon solo en moto y un dia no
Logré legar al dueño, debes darme
noche y te digo que es de dia en el amazonas ahi
el sirviente es precioso
sus colores discurren unidos por la
árboles en la noche el aislamiento y
oscuridad recuerdo que manejé
amigo yo moto y un carro mañana
gusto por los árboles no era
posible admirar el violonchelo se convertiría en un faro
de la motocicleta iluminó admirados pares de
errores de animales que también apunté
solo pensé y abla a mi mismo
las calmas son gatos y perrucci en el
un poco de equilibrio
Sin embargo, no fue porque la gente
pregunta por el miedo porque es de
La naturaleza humana no es sólo el miedo a
cometer un error es mucho más grande que nosotros
tragando avance quiero serlo pero aprende
sobre este peligroso compañero de todos
en la vida es el grado miedo eso es lo que he sido
jugador de voleibol de playa
diez años
atacar una lesión grave pero el color de la
tribunales y ahora mismo
youtube déjalo reír entre el trabajo
garantías convencionales utilizadas en las que había
estudiado mientras el jugador o en el pensamiento
el diseño de las decoraciones para ser un gran
documental de motos por el sur de
America
sin embargo sin estar garantizado sado yloise
porque por dos razones la primera porque
lavadora
camino de corazones no quería uno
trabajar el trabajo
yo queria tener pasion es la segunda
la razon es por estos unidos sabe
estos unidos
que lo hicieron juntos después de todo es una señal de allí
clase y la universidad y en la escuela y
cuando escuchamos se une lo que nos
vamos a casa vamos a salir
infelicidad todavía en una escuela
cómo la universidad es un regalo de vida
intenso donde están en las elecciones
las oportunidades de los amigos para
queremos salir a casa muchas
revolucionamos y lo firmaremos mismo
en nuestros trabajos
laurinda previene cuando escuchamos unidos
para ir a casa
No es un placer que no quisiera eso
Quería hacerlo y hoy digo cuando estoy
siendo yo mismo trabajo documental hay muchos
investigaciones para ser y estoy en mi
taller por horas y cuando miro lo que es
demasiado tarde para que no haya andre
Quiero irme porque porque no extra
barrio azul en passione y cuando
encontramos en esta pasión que encontramos en el
conexiones adicionales
es muy común entre las personas que dijeron
el gran viaje y cuando regresaron
intercambian su vida pensando en el
Universidad
cambiasso trabajo abrir una empresa
cerrar una empresa
sin embargo, ¿por qué no lo cierras antes?
allí en su mayoría en la tripulación que viaja nuestro
epner distintas visiones de lo que somos
acostumbrados a apuntar a nuevos escenarios nuevos
oportunidades y cuando tenemos nuevas
oportunidades nuevas visiones de campeones en el
semestre la cabeza y nos prestamos para estar ahí
las preguntas correctas en 2014 sobre
amazona fue encontrada tribu india
que nunca han tenido contacto con otros
humanos cómo vivían como animales y cómo
salvaje
rio en casitas cas alan escala es
muy probablemente irían como el tuyo
antepasados ​​hace dos mil años en un
nada evolutivo
sin embargo, a unos 2.000 kilómetros de la
mismo lugar dos mil años antes
Los Incas hicieron y engrandecieron
construcciones en paracas como esta
cirugía de cabeza
la luz en las casas llevaba el agua por
bajo el desierto decían grano aquí y
conductos
la pregunta que tenemos es ser un juego
como investigador y america las tejas
con los estudiantes como profesionales es
porque un poema azul evoluciona tanto y
otro poema en la nada evolutiva ahi
necesitar
no creo en la amazonia es muy hostil
los ríos crecen como 13 metros en el
Las respuestas a estas preguntas están en el
historias de nuestra america en son
ampollas son en las personas en 1970
y 12 un avión uruguayo con 45 personas de
un equipo de rani se quedó en la mesa de imi
con didira de lujo relevante para
mantenerse con vida tuvo que recurrir a
cuerpos de amigos que habían muerto este
historia conocida como el milagro de
Los Andes
si pudiéramos ser una experiencia para
mira qué lmp de un ser humano eres y
caer en la prueba perfecta
tomamos un avión con 45 personas para
la mayoría rueda fuerte
acostumbrado al clima ten un plan vamos a ponerlo
ni el avión y el poder la limitaban
despertar dire a 3.400 metros de altitud
en el lugar que te falta y podremos
30 graduados de arcilla cero donde no la hay
ningún ser vivo no es alimento
no hay agua y vamos a ver que tal
límites del ser humano por lo que es un
gran documental sobre esta historia
en 2012 y durante todo el proyecto
Siempre he estado detrás de una pregunta que
esta pregunta correcta 45 personas incluso
dale con didira y 16 super live
qué fichas son estas personas
fuerte tus habilidades
el ft y despues de tener y tio toda la ruta
para verlo 57 uno en moto desde uruguay
atacaron a didira donde cometieron el error de
navegación en el estado donde el
restos de avion en dolares
cordillera en chile la banda con super
viviendo con gente ella con desprecio con
Equipos de rescate
la respuesta a esta pregunta estaba en
piloto del equipo de rescate de chile
amados sobrevivieron porque no sabían que
nos fue imposible la palabra que tu
teton o chilena para poder limitarse en
cordillera durante siete días
yo las mismas condiciones que estaban
los dorados los uruguayos es probable que
Chileno morirá el 3
por que porque sabes lo terrible que es
esta la cocinera o la implacable
sin embargo los uruguayos sin saber que era
imposible
sobrevivirá adaptado y no cambiará
aprendido de la naturaleza y logrado
vivir 72 días en estas condiciones
esta es una gran gloria una gran pelota
de nuestras cualidades como latinoamerica
como latinoamericanos en su capacidad de
adaptación a diferentes escenarios y a
este es un gran ciclo de éxito para el
otros que queremos ser pero podemos ser
que conquistan nuestros miedos
entrar en esta pasión esta conexión con
este mundo con es el lugar correcto
conoce la historia de america del sur
que nos cambien y lleguemos al show
los sueños
seamos nuestros sueños, no seamos los
ese semus repetidamente
sin embargo, nuestros sueños nos muestran nuestro
desafilado
seamos nuestros videos lo que olvidamos
de monstruo
esta es una medida de los incas en casa un
marca kaká están en los 14 sapa incas que
¿Estaban libres del cuerpo del imperio Inca?
debajo de cada estatua hay una placa con
tu sombra tu dinastía y no con tu
sueños con temas por lo que se recuerda
cada uno de nosotros los demás un presentador ca
estamos construyendo un tablero como este
día no serán años pero ahí está nuestro
familia nuestros vecinos nuestros amigos
recordará nuestras hachas
que aporte somos
velando por nuestra familia por nuestra
ciudad que cartel estamos construyendo
tal vez como todavía capac joven poderoso
o mundo transformer pachacuti
no de todos del mundo al tuyo
alrededor
tu familia tu comunidad
sin embargo, sin etios podemos ser recordados
como mayta capac es un nicho melancolico
sin legados amigos
está en nuestras manos está el futuro de nuestra
la comunidad de nuestra familia es el futuro
de america y mas que el investigador
de america fue el mensajero de america y
por las zapatillas que quieren ser pero traigo
un mensaje de hermanos que encontraste
para toda la carrera
quiero ser pero aprender de los hermanos
cuando quieres conservarte y limitarte
se refiere a la vinculación mientras que la agonía a
energía lunar con éxito para un amor a
sabe muslo reinado en blumenau avenida a
quien tenia la carta de garantia argumentar
surgió una maravilla que valió la pena para el
lo que noé jon lord otto en la vida cuando tu
conecta la naturaleza, se humaniza y comienza
persiguiendo algo que anteayer hubo
portador del tiempo pensando en el paso a
gloria conectar naturaleza convincente
paraíso como este normalmente me siento
eso es humano y tranquilo aqui en el trofeo
dodo y osmar a todos y que la vida pasa
muy rapido
[Música]
porque no es fácil empezó el viernes de sal
son nuestros hermanos lo que esperan de
incluso si la familia adicional con sus
amigos que defienden su futuro
América como agradecimiento por la compañía en
viaje
[Aplausos]